welcome to exploring computing
today's video is computer security
malware
so we're going to continue our
discussion on computer security and
today's videos are going to focus on
ways that you can be attacked and things
that can be done
to you and the next lecture will focus
on ways you can protect yourself
so i want to start off by talking about
malware
malware is basically the term comes from
malicious software
and this is software that can get
installed on your computer and do some
nasty stuff
specifically we're going to talk about
spyware ransomware adware
how your computer can be turned into a
zombie computer and placed in a botnet
and then i'll also discuss logic bombs
all right so let's start off with
spyware spyware is
software that has been installed on your
computer that
is designed to spy on you
so we saw this with the dalai lama
example from the previous lecture where
uh the computers in its office were
infected by something called
ghost rat for remote access tool
and connect to the ghost net
i think the spyware is particularly
problematic
on modern computer and mobile devices
because of the
specific capabilities of our computers
or mobile devices
it's always been very problematic but i
think
now more than ever it's really a problem
okay so what sort of things can spyware
be
used for well the first thing is it can
be used to key log
and so what this means is it's going to
track all of your keystrokes so if you
go to your bank for example it's going
to
keep track of your username as you type
it in and then it will
keep track of your password as you type
that in as well
and this information will all be sent
over through the network
to the attacking person
um spyware can also copy files so
for example if you've got information
about financial information
on your computer you can go ahead and
take those files and send them somewhere
remotely
um now one of the things that it can do
on a modern computer or a modern
mobile device that they didn't used to
be able to do is we all have microphones
and cameras and so
it can be used to turn on the microphone
and listen to what you're
saying in a room it can turn on the
camera
also because modern mobile devices keep
track of your movements
uh spyware can be used to track you
all right ransomware when it gets on
your computer what it does is it
encrypts your entire
solid state drive or your entire hard
drive and it asks for payment to decrypt
your
uh information so basically locks your
information
and it requires payment typically in
bitcoin in order to unlock
your device um so an example of
ransomware is the wannacry so this is
a ransomware which uh was released in
2017 and it infected over 200 000
computers in over 150
countries uh it demanded bitcoin
payments from
300 to 600 depending on how soon you
paid it off
and i took down large parts of the
british national health service
it caused so much disruption to the
british national health service that
the british health service was forced to
turn away patients except for in
critical situations
this particular piece of software used
an exploit that was
known about in microsoft windows
and so people that had updated their
copy microsoft windows were protected
and people that didn't
were vulnerable to this attack it's
believed to have been
north korean origin although not known
for sure
um there's actually multiple uses of the
term ad where
um some people use it to just refer to
any program that displays
ads so for example so i have
mirror webster app on my mobile devices
and
when you run it you can look up words
for free it will read the words to you
for free which
i think is a glorious feature
particularly for people learning
foreign languages having dictionaries
which can speak words to is amazing
and i will say i do find it useful in
english as well
and you can use the merriam-webster app
for free
because it displays advertisements
similarly i have
the weather channel app on my mobile
device and again
uh you don't have to pay for it it
displays little ads at the bottom of the
app so some people do consider these
adware
i don't but you can certainly see where
the term comes from
i'm going to use the term adword to
refer to software that
is maliciously installed on your
computer
or surreptitiously installed on your
computer that displays ads you do not
know where the advertisements are coming
from
and so when you're running your computer
you will see random ads sometimes this
will be random ads showing up on the web
browser when you're browsing the web and
they have
nothing to do with the website that
you're visiting
the website that you're visiting is not
getting money from the ads that the
adwords displaying
and sometimes these can just display ads
whether or not you're on
the uh whether or not you're on the web
so
um you know this is clearly an
altogether
different level than ad supported
applications like the dictionary and
weather apps i talked about earlier
where it's very clear
you're only going to see ads when you're
running that particular application
and those ads are being used to pay for
the free service that you're receiving
that's not the case with adware adware
is
installed typically without your
permission sometimes it's installed
we'll talk about this a little bit later
but it's installed with your permission
because there's a big
lengthy terms of agreement that you just
click
through and say yeah yeah yeah okay this
all looks fine
and it turns out one of the terms is
we're going to install something nasty
on your computer
so um
that's uh that's adware um
and i do generally i use the term only
to represent the malicious version of
this software although again some people
do refer to adware as
uh as anything that displays
advertisements or pays for itself using
advertisements
okay another ad related issue that's
come up pretty recently
is as you know when
your computer visits different websites
the computer can run
software associated with that website
and particularly if they're running
client-side javascript
it turns out that some websites are now
mining for cryptocurrency when you're
visiting your their website so this is
uh
well it's unclear what the morality or
legality of this is i suppose it's
probably legal
it's unclear what the morality of this
is um i mean you are visiting their
website as long as it only runs when
they're visiting your website and stops
as soon as you leave i suppose one can
make a
a reasonable case that this is this is
not illegal or immoral but um there have
been reports of
uh websites that do this sort of thing
uh having some sorts of issues where
it gets served up by an ad network um or
it locks up your computer
so anyway potentially problematics is
something to be aware of and
yet another threat
okay zombie computers this is another
thing that can be done
when malicious software gets installed
on your computer
basically what happens with the zombie
computer is malware is installed on your
computer that gives a remote user
complete control over your computer the
control computers
are referred to zombie computers or bots
and zombie computers or bots
are typically put into groups because
these are most useful
in a group of computers not a single
zombie computer
and the group of computers combined
together is what we refer to as a bot
network
i did want to mention that there are
several different uses of the term bot
and most of the uses are not malicious
so
if you hear the term but don't
immediately think that's necessarily a
bad thing so
some of the uses of the term bot are
independent program that's
out crawling the internet so example
this would be the google bot
which is a program that google uses to
request different web pages and it's
what it uses to form
the index information that google gives
you the term bot
can also be used to just refer to any
uh program that's independently acting
on someone's behalf
it sort of comes from the term robot
anyway i just wanted to mention that so
again
even though bought in this particular
case in
in the use particularly with bot
networks is a bad thing
um if you do hear somebody referring to
computers and use the term bot that's
not necessarily
a negative term by itself
so what are bot networks used for well
one common use of bot networks is to
send spam so
we've all got unwanted emails um
sometimes they're scam emails and so one
question may be like
why is this allowed why can't i just
block the spam emails
and so one of the issues with spam
emails is if all the spam emails come
from the same computer are the same
couple computers
then we can just all block them so one
thing that these bot networks are used
is to send spam emails from many many
different computers from all over the
world
which makes them much harder to block
another use is distributed denial
service attacks so
denial of service attack is when you
attempt to deliberately overwhelm a
computer
by making many many requests on it so
i always use the example um suppose
stanford students want to bring down the
cal computers
during big game don't do this by the way
this is a
violation of stanford's terms of service
for your use of stamford computers so
and the stanford network so don't do
this but suppose we all decided we were
going to
um on a lark bring down the cal
computers
during big game week uh what we could do
is everybody on stanford campus could
just repeatedly hit the cal computers
and at some point the cal computer's
load would be exceeded and legitimate
users trying to access the cal web
computers would not be able to access it
all right so what happens here well cal
kind of looks at
uh they're like we seem to be getting a
ton of requests our computers are
getting overwhelmed
what's going on oh look all the requests
are coming from stanford university and
as you all know now because
you've been taking my class uh all the
stanford computers have the same
or very similar ip numbers so the first
couple digits in the ip number are the
same
and so caltech support says well screw
that
we're just blocking any request to cal
coming from
a stanford ip number so that's a
standard denial of service attack and
obviously they're annoying and a lot of
work for
tech people to deal with but they can be
blocked because they are coming from a
specific computer specific range of
computers
so what a distributed denial service
attack does is it says
well okay we don't want to have our
request denied because they're coming
from a specific ip range what we're
going to do is we've got this bot
network composed of zombie computers all
around the world and we will instruct
all the bots in our bot network to hit
the cal computers
and by the way now we're getting into
very illegal territory so
don't do this and
so at that point cal can't really do
anything about it because
they see many many different ip numbers
and there's no specific range of
computers that they can go ahead and ban
so um
all right so that's a distributed denial
of service attack and in order to do a
distributed denial of service attack you
do need something like a bot network
with many computers which are
geographically dispersed okay another
use of bot networks is click fraud
so there's two variants of click fraud
um so one variant of click fraud
you have a website that is displaying
advertisements and you want to increase
the
uh the ad revenue and so what you do is
you have
uh basically fake advertising clicking
where
um you know normally you're going to get
paid for the advertisements you display
on your website particularly on the
basis of the number of people that
actually click on that ad
and look at the website that that
advertisement is
advertising and so what you can do is
you can
use a bot network to have
different computers from around the
world visit your website and click on
the ads on your website and that will
increase your ad revenue
um again also highly illegal
alternatively what you can do is you can
say hey
my competitor has this big ad campaign
going on
what we're going to do is we are going
to deliberately visit websites that are
displaying
our competitors advertisements and
our bots are going to click on those ads
no human beings are involved so uh
you know nobody's actually going to see
those advertisements or click through
and look at their actual
website or the products that they're
selling but it will look like they are
and so
basically our competitor's ad money is
all going to go
to paying off the ad network for
ads that only our bots are actually
clicking on and no real people are
actually seeing
so that's click fraud um just to provide
an example of an actual bot network uh
the burrito lab
worm slash virus uh we'll talk about
worms and viruses momentarily
i infected over 30 million computers and
it was infecting at
a rate of about 3 million computers per
month
what did this thing do well it stole
financial information i remember we
talked about spyware copying files
earlier
it sent out billions of emails including
emails which were infected with itself
to try and further
expand uh the burrito network here
it included a key logger to keep track
of whatever people typed to get access
to their passwords and other information
but also it took all those computers
that it had affected and created a bot
network which could be
rented by third parties for 139 000 a
month
um there is a link to the article
thank you maddie that's enough there is
a link to the article
discussing this network in today's
class notes
okay uh here's another thing that can be
placed in a program
this one's a little bit different
because um
this isn't malicious software that's
been
installed on your computer this is
actually
a program that includes something
malicious in the program which
often was added there by the original
programmer
so this is called a logic bomb and
essentially a logic bomb is something in
a piece of software which
triggers under specific circumstances so
um you've probably seen examples of
logic bombs in movies
so you know there's a lot of stuff going
on in movies that seems to be complete
bug
but a logic bomb is actually doable so
a logic bomb occurs when for example
somebody reads a specific file
you can trigger some action based on hey
this file got red
or uh when somebody tries to modify a
file and so the idea is
this is something added to the program
or to the operating system
that uh is not part of its intended use
that a programmer has placed
into this program where if a specific
action occurs
it's going to go off and do something
that something may just be
sending an email because sometimes just
knowing that somebody is reading a file
could be useful information
or it could be something much more
malicious i saw an example on wikipedia
that i rather liked that
a programmer who was fired could set up
a logic bomb where
if they were removed from payroll or
somehow payroll mark them as fired it
could
do something malicious like for example
delete files or something like that so
you know i think that's a good example
of a logic bomb
but again you know i think this is one
of the few examples where
stuff happens in movies and you're like
yeah okay that
that that's actually related to an
actual technique that uh that can be
done
okay so uh how does this malware get on
your computer
there's a number of different causes of
malware and so we're going to talk about
a bunch of these we're talking about
viruses
worms and trojan horses also i've
mentioned zero day exploits before but
we'll take a closer look at that
and i should mention that there's
overlap between these so
you know we actually saw this a minute
ago with uh burrito lab well there's a
virus or worm well actually was both so
um there are pieces of software that can
cover more
than one of these in fact there are
pieces of software that can cover all
three of these virus worms and trojan
horses i suppose all four
because it might be based on a day zero
zero day exploit
okay so what is a virus a virus is a
computer program
which attaches itself to other programs
and so the idea here is
um you've got a bunch of programs on
your computer and so what the virus is
going to do is when it runs it will look
for other executable programs on your
computer
and it will add to the instructions
in that program copies of itself so the
next time you run that other program
the virus code will run there's
different ways that the virus figures
out which programs to attach itself to
sometimes it's designed to attach
specific programs sometimes it looks for
programs that are running and tries to
attach itself to them but the basic idea
here is the virus
replicates itself by attaching itself to
different programs
potentially anything that can be
executed can be
infected and this often includes files
that you don't normally think of as
executables so
zip files for example there's versions
of zip files which include executable
code
which will run when somebody tries to
open up the zip file and this is
actually why stanford's computers
uh stanford's email computers no longer
allow you to send zip files you can kind
of get that warning and they're like
no we don't want people to be send or
receive zip files because they are
potentially infected
microsoft office documents can include
scripting information
and so because script is essentially a
program
they can include viruses so viruses can
add themselves to
microsoft documents um and
actually you may notice now uh
this this got added relatively recently
i think maybe in the last five years
where um when you get a copy of a word
document or
or maybe an excel document from somebody
um
it will start off and you won't be able
to edit it
and it'll be like are you sure you want
to move into edit mode
and so this is again to protect against
these sort of situations
it's basically running it's allowing you
to view the contents of that document in
sort of a more protectant mode
in case there's something malicious
within that document
and then it's only when you're like yeah
i'm sure i know who sent this to me
um this was extracted and i'm pretty
sure that they
practice safe computing hopefully uh so
yeah let's go ahead and open this so i
can go ahead and edit it
and so that's what's going on there it's
trying to protect you from uh
viruses attached to the document
okay a worm is a program that propagates
copies of
itself on the network and so we saw an
example of this
last lecture when i talked about i love
you which was
a program that
was actually a combination of several
things it was it was an email that you
received
that said i love you and then there was
an attachment on it
and if you open up the attachment it was
actually
a visual basic script which ran
on microsoft outlook which is their
email program
looking at all of the addresses in your
outlook email book and sending copies of
itself to everybody
in the email book so
this is a worm in the sense that
it is making copies of itself and
propagating itself through a network
okay a trojan horse is a program that
either does something other than what it
claims to do or
possibly does exactly what it claims to
do but also
includes a malicious payload on top of
it
so just to provide a couple examples we
talked previously about how the dalai
lama
got attacked with the ghost spyware
program
by opening a document called translation
of free movement for
tibetans in exile.doc so you know it
seems like it was legitimate
but it in fact was not actually uh that
document
or potentially was that document but in
addition to the document had a malicious
playload attached to the document
um certainly i love you uh you know
i guess people were like hey somebody
loves me they sent me attachment i
should open this up and see what it is
um yeah they didn't love you
sorry and then uh there's also been a
bunch of
fun quote fun applications like uh
weather programs um which you install
the weather program
and you know i mentioned this earlier if
you read through the terms of service
it's like
oh and i'm going to install this nasty
thing on your computer
and there was another example where
there was basically a cartoon
character that would appear on your
desktop
and people like oh that sounds like fun
i should go ahead and install this
and it installed that program but did
some other malicious stuff in the
background so
these are examples of trojan horses they
are either
things which
are completely malicious uh like
i love you or they are
potentially they do one thing but they
do some other stuff in the background so
like maybe the weather
applications actually do show the
weather but they also
install adware that continues to display
advertisements even after you stop using
the program
or in the case of the buddy program you
know they show
the bear buddy but in addition to the
bear buddy they
installed some stuff on your computer so
uh those are all trojan horses okay i
mentioned zero day exploits before you
may recall
um last lecture we were talking about
stuxnet that was the
program which was designed to attack the
iranian
nuclear centrifuges
and we talked about how there were four
different zero-day exploits
associated with that program so
basically a program
which uses a zero day exploit is using
weakness that is
not known by uh security researchers
and so the idea here is your computer is
not protected against zero day exploits
this is something that nobody knows
about except for the person that
has the zero day exploit and this is the
sorts of things that
you know nation state security
apparatuses like
for example the nsa are all about hey
can we find an exploit and then the
question is
are we going to tell microsoft about
this exploit are we going to keep it in
our back pocket so we can use it to
attack other countries
so you can't directly
defend against a zero day exploit
because you don't know what it is
uh and the people that made your
software don't know what it is
but uh you can still practice safe
computing and we'll talk about uh things
that you can do next lecture that will
um
hopefully make it harder for somebody
with a day zero exploit tool to
actually get it on your computer and
have it run
and take advantage of the weakness in
your software
on the other hand kind of the opposite
of software which is using a zero data
exploit is
there are many different attacks that
occur that are just variants of
pre-existing attack so
you know software that can be used to
attack computers just kind of floating
around the internet
um and hackers can go ahead and just
grab it
and you know either just use it directly
or make a bunch of tweaks to it and use
that
and some security experts refer to
people
that just take these pre-existing
programs and use them to attack people
as
script kitties so this is sort of a
derogatory term that
those experts use when referring to
these hackers that maybe
aren't as sophisticated and can't
actually come up with their own
uh ways of attacking computers so you
know
there's a lot of stuff already out there
um now the thing about the stuff that's
already out there is because
we do know it's out there uh your
operating system manufacturer knows it's
out there your web browser manufacturers
know it's out there these are not
zero-day exploits and so when the when
these
sorts of things are discovered once upon
a time they were zero-day exploits they
are now discovered it's a known thing
they go ahead and patch their software
to prevent
these tools from being able to attack
your computer and so this is why you
really need to keep your software
updated
you